what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with dark crisis now here's the
thing the conclusion of this story is
going to give us a pretty huge
jaw-dropping moment and I'm entirely
excited to see how it is you guys
respond to it but what this does is this
picks up off the heels of the last video
that we did so as always if you guys
want to get caught up or if you're new
here make sure you check out the
playlist down in the description that'll
get you caught up on everything but the
long and short of this is that again
Pariah up until about the last issue had
been the main villain of the story that
the idea was that Pariah was using the
great darkness which was just really
this kind of enigmatic force that exists
in DC Comics that really up until this
story and the old Swamp Thing story from
the original crisis on Infinity door
stories that we didn't really know a
whole lot about it it was just kind of
the antithesis of the presence or God so
if you want to apply like morality to
this the presence represents absolute
good and the great Darkness represents
absolute evil but not really because one
of the things that we've learned is the
great Darkness isn't really an evil
being it just represents the absence of
anything right just the end of all
things is more or less what it is but
Pariah was using his power in order to
bring back the original Multiverse that
was destroyed during the events of
crisis on infinite Earth now where
Pariah has been defeated here the great
darkness's power was passed to
Deathstroke now it's kind of an
interesting choice as to why this was
done by Joshua Williamson I'm not
entirely sure this could have happened
with virtually anybody and it would have
just made good sense now the funny thing
about this is that while this battle is
going on we actually get this commentary
from seemingly Deathstroke himself where
he says you said it yourself Richards
the darkness never goes away well really
Richard he's talking about Dick Grayson
Richard Grayson that kind of thing but
he says you can light some pretty
candles and make all the hopeful
speeches that you want but in the end
the light always prevails it's all we're
left with is the only true Legacy Pariah
was a certifiable loon thought he was
talking to some great darkness when it
was really just the voices in his head
until he bit the dust but the darkness
he created lives on and it's got you too
pulling you backward stripping you of
all that you've become but unlike Pariah
You are not alone now here's the funny
thing about this right like here's the
interesting thing about this this runs
in stark contrast I know it's going to
sound a little strange to kind of pull
this out of the hat but it runs in stark
contrast to like Superboy Prime and the
reason why is because in a lot of ways
if you break them down on the Character
level Dick Grayson and Superboy Prime
were opposites but similar at the same
time the idea of Dick Grayson is that he
was the first Robin right and so from a
publishing side in DC Comics when they
were releasing stories he was like the
young kid who wanted to be Batman
sidekick and it worked really really
well right I mean Comics sold like
gangbusters but within the comic book
landscape itself Dick Grayson as Robin
brought a kind of youthful Vibrance to
DC Comics that it didn't really have at
the time right being able to see the
world through the eyes of a child and so
over the course of his characters really
publication history in DC while he has
had good times and bad times and he's
had some really really bad times that
kind of light to the world never really
went away it always kind of stayed there
and that's the reason why in a lot of
ways Dick Grayson is seen in DC Comics
as the best of all the superheroes
because no matter how bad things get and
as a superhero who operates in
bloodhaven which is arguably worse than
Gotham City that he always maintains
that measure of happiness that
exuberance that the day can be saved
that hope is not lost no matter how hard
the enemy tries that if they hold out
the good fight they can always come out
on top and stark contrast to this
Superboy Prime was a character who
believed that the age of the anti-heroes
Batman kind of turning the line between
the good guy and the bad guy even
Superman to a degree doing that that
superheroes had quote unquote lost their
purpose they weren't Heroes anymore they
were just bad guys masquerading as
Heroes and then occasionally doing good
things but these characters are complete
opposites but very similar in that way I
draw that parallel because in a lot of
ways what you're seeing with Slade here
is very reminiscent of Superboy product
it's very reminiscent of the old like
Superboy Prime stories from Infinite
Crisis and really kind of the aftermath
going into like Celestial core War and
the Green Lantern Comics by Jeff Johns
in the sense of Slade Wilson is very
much cynical here and to a degree a
narcissist and you would even argue a
nihilist depending on how you wanna how
you want to look at it here but the
thing about it is he tells Dick Grayson
while dick Grayson's kind of Trapped in
the darkness Slade Wilson literally
tells him look at everything going on
out there right the superheroes are
throwing everything at me but the
kitchen sink but at the end of the day
they're not going to be able to hold the
lawn and the reason why is because they
are dark right because they do fight off
that dark part of themselves but they're
not you Dick Grayson and if I can
conquer you right if the great Darkness
can snare and take over you what chance
do any of these guys have now the funny
thing about this is he says it's like
the rest of our lives pointless even if
I kick the bucket out there the darkness
will find a new home nothing can stop it
and so a Dick Grayson asked why did you
do this it's so unlike you which is true
it is it's not really in the character
of Slade Wilson to allow himself to fall
prey to something like this but Dick
Grayson asked how much of this is you
and how much was pariah's control he
says at the start it was Pariah it was
Prime manipulating me Whispering words
in my head you know just kind of
tricking me and so on and so forth he
says but he made a good argument our
world needs to die and he says I've seen
this world hurt my children too many
times and the funny thing about this is
that it looks like from what Slade
Wilson's saying that he's actually
hiding behind really like the world
itself in order to avoid the
consequences of his own actions right
it's him literally saying like the world
has hurt my children the world's done
terrible things to my children and
that's where Slade's at at the moment
right at this moment right now it's
easier to simply just avoid the fact
that the guy was a terrible dad and the
guy did Terrible Things to his kids and
put them In Harm's Way and even tried to
kill them on a couple of occasions right
now he does kind of admit to a degree
right like I was the one that brought
that hurt into their lives but again
he's not really coming clean and
admitting fall here it's more or less
him saying yeah yeah I brought the hurt
another life but if it wasn't for the
world that hurt wouldn't exist in the
first place so the hurt the world has to
go away the the world has to the world
has to has to end it's all got to go
away it's walking in as you have this
fight kind of breaking out you do have
some Heroes who sort of pop up Damien
Wayne shows up with like justice
incarnate different things along those
lines but he also ends up bringing in
doctor life so here's something to
understand when it comes to Dr Light in
the old days in DC Comics Dr Light was a
person who could manipulate light and
there were a few other things that could
go with it during dark crisis Dark Army
that tie-in with Damian Wayne and all
them one of the things that we learn is
that Dr Light was actually gifted with
the ability to tap into the source right
the energy of all creation now that's an
astronomical power boost right it's like
being able to tap in for those of you
guys coming from Marvel Comics it's like
being able to tap into the power of the
one above all right it's just a
ridiculous source of energy that a
person can use although DC's use of the
source is a lot more tamed down than the
kind of flights of fantasy that you see
in Marvel Comics when it comes comes to
like insane levels of power like the one
above all or the beyonders or but let me
try butyl or something along those lines
but the important thing here is that
being able to tap into the source also
means being able to manipulate the
entire basis behind the Multiverse
itself and so given what's said here
this is something that's really really
important right Damien says I uncover
that Dr Light is connected to the
Multiverse the same way Pariah was to
the darkness and so in turn Dr Light
says I absorb the light that created the
Multiverse and I believe I can use it to
illuminate the darkness what we're
talking about here are avatars and not
that dissimilar avatars when it comes to
Pariah in Dr Light if Pariah was a guy
who could tap into the power of the
great darkness and use the power of the
great Darkness for its own end the
source is kind of the antithesis the
opposite of the great darkness and so Dr
Light being able to tap into the source
means she can tap into the light of
creation so she can effectively undo
what Pariah had done the difference here
is that Pariah is far more Adept at
being able to now navigate and
manipulate the Multiverse because he's
been around for so long and because his
history is irrevocably tied to the
Multiverse itself for Pariah navigating
the Multiverse is his first language for
Dr Light she's still learning the basics
right she's still learning like simple
forms of communication hello how are you
doing that kind of thing now the reality
is that given everything that's going on
and before the Justice League was even
aware of the fact that Dr Light was tied
to the Multiverse they sent the various
flashes into the Multiverse itself in
order to try to find some way to free
the Multiverse of the darkness's control
because remember the darkness is still
permeating out there in the Multiverse
it's still doing its thing it's become
less of a focus because now we're more
focused on what's happening on Earth but
that's still going on there now there
isn't a whole lot they can do here they
can move to the Multiverse but they need
an extra source of power Dr Light
realizing this travels to meet with the
speedsters now at that point you switch
over to what's arguably the best moment
in the comic and it's really cool the
way that it happened so what you end up
doing is you actually pick up with Black
Adam facing off against Deathstroke now
the fight between Black Adam and slate
is really cool because while all this is
going on you have Mr terrific who kind
of says we still need a way to stop
Slade and the Dark Army and that's where
Black Adam comes in he's like that is my
sacrifice to make and he says Darkseid
warned me that I was the key to
defeating you I should have seen it but
there is much that I've been blind to
even after I dismiss the heroes they
still saved me when I betrayed them I
thought that only I had the will and the
power to stop the darkness but I was
right and that is why my name is Black
Adam and in doing so and this is kind of
something we have to talk about here for
a second in doing so he gives the
entirety of the Justice League and
really the larger superhero Community is
Powers literally they all are able to
tap into the power of Black Adam which
is kind of nuts right like Black Adam
takes over the Justice League or the
Justice League all become Black Adams
however you want to slice it they're all
able to tap into his abilities now the
thing about this and the way the black
Adam's being handled here this is
completely ignored boring basically Jeff
John's run on Shazam and the Seven magic
lands and the reason why is because at
the end of that story block Adam joined
the Shazam family he was a tried and
true good guy he turned it all around
right this story and basically the way
black items handled here ignores all of
that and that's why those of us who are
reading this story who are basically DC
Comic fans or at least have read DC
Comics enough to understand a reboot
when it happens or all looking at this
and saying this is a reboot right
because what it's doing is it's
basically writing out elements of story
lines that have either happened recently
or are currently happening now but the
important thing here kind of leaving
that bit aside the important thing here
is that the entirety of the Justice
League now United under the power of
Black Adam that power bolsters their own
so it's like Superman combined with the
powers of Black Adam Green Lanterns
combined with the powers of Black Adam I
also just kind of want to throw this out
here Superman and Batman look nuts it is
amazing but this is where you get to the
beauty of the other part of the
situation you have this kind of
conversation that goes on between Slade
Wilson and Nightwing himself that this
kind of takes place simultaneously with
the attempt of the great Darkness to
overtake everything specifically to
overtake Nightwing now that's the
significance of all of this is because
while Dr Light is able to combine her
powers with those of the speedsters and
then basically push the great Darkness
back to its original resting place right
basically saving the Multiverse what
this does is it takes the new Multiverse
or kind of the old Multiverse from
before crisis on infiniters and it
combines it with the new Multiverse that
was created in the aftermath of final
crisis really Infinite Crisis final
crisis and the new 52. so what DC has
effectively done here if I'm reading
this correctly what they've done here is
they've combined multiverses they've
brought back the original Multiverse and
they combined it with the new Multiverse
basically it's a kind of unification
everything that ever existed before the
events of crisis on infinite Earth
exists again and it exists along side
the main DC Universe as we've been
viewing it since Infinite Crisis final
crisis in the new 52 in 2011. that means
the old school Earth 2 Superman exists
now that guy is presumably back
hopefully we'll get a chance to explore
all that stuff but I'm not entirely sure
again only time will tell in terms of
what all this means but the bigger thing
here is the fight between Slade and
Black Adam is amazing because what Slade
says is I'm surprised at you Black Adam
and he says you know as well as I do
these new kids are not worth our time
right these new superheroes who are
running around out here who are taking
on kind of the mantle of their Protege
why would you fight alongside all of
them why would you protect them and the
response of Black Adam is I would die
with them now this is exceedingly
important and the reason why is because
for someone like Black Adam he's been
around for a long long time his main
enemy is Shazam but he's fought Superman
he's fought Batman he's basically run
the gamut of pretty much every superhero
who exists out there there's really
nobody in DC Comics better suited to
offer an actual concrete analysis of
whether or not any of these young heroes
are worth the time and effort of
basically teaching or training or
anything like that but Dick Grayson and
it's kind of an interesting way they put
it here Dick Grayson is not Batman he
was never Batman he was a robin and
eventually became his own superhero but
the reality here is he was the first in
a new generation of Heroes who followed
after their mentors and so that's why
you have Slade kind of referring to Dick
Grayson to a degree as like a poor man's
Batman that's why you have him asking
the question why would you fight
alongside all these younger Heroes well
the funny thing about this is that Dick
Grayson says Bruce wouldn't fight the
dark right I must let the darkness in I
must take it on myself and seemingly is
succumbed by the darkness but that's
where you have Dick Grayson who kind of
dispels this perception of the different
superheroes who exist out there right
the Slade says touching it appears the
Multiverse gets to Live Another Day
Black Adam but we must stop the children
from following in our footsteps now
again while Slade's not directly having
this conversation with Dick Grayson Dick
Grayson can hear it all and that's when
Dick races says you'll never get it
slayed we're not following in anyone's
footsteps all of us walk together no
matter the world or generation we
embrace our history alongside the new to
bring hope to everyone now this is an
exceedingly important point that Joshua
Williamson is making here because what
Joshua Williamson is really saying here
is that for a lot of people out there
they would look at like Dick Grayson
they would say he's not Batman well no
of course he's not he never was he was
started out as Robin and then he became
like Nightwing he kind of operated as
Batman for a little while but was never
designed to be a replacement of Batman
that what Dick Grayson is doing really
Joshua Williamson by way of Dick Grayson
is kind of countering this point of
people who say I don't want things to
change I want Comics to stay the same
forever right it's one of those things
where that doesn't happen the reality
here is that Dick Grayson sure is not a
Batman and he never was that none of
these Heroes these younger Heroes you
know Jonathan Kent for example kind of
operating a Superboy they're not looking
to like copy or replace any of those
existing Heroes they're carving out
their own Niche now that is a clear and
obvious point that DC's made over and
over again the only people who don't
grasp that are the ones who choose not
to for whatever reason they make sense
to themselves but the bigger Point here
is that none of these heroes are looking
to walk in the footsteps of anybody
they're carving out their own Niche
they're becoming their own hero stepping
into their own roles and it's a really
really interesting point to make here
because there have kind of been
instances in the past when DC Comics has
tried to take a hero and take a younger
hero and replace an older hero with that
younger hero what Joshua Williamson is
doing here is clean slating all of that
again it's DC picking and choosing what
they want to keep in order to kind of
balance out the scales and make sure
that the comic line is the most
interesting to the largest number of
people but it's one of those interesting
Concepts because what you have is Slade
who again tries to go after like like
Dick Grayson and then his daughter jumps
in the way and says stop right like this
is over the great darkness is done it
doesn't have his control over you
anymore it's pushed back to its place
the Multiverse is saved what are you
fighting for like like what are you
fighting for like if your fight here
really is this idea that you are afraid
that the world is such a terrible and
horrible place that you want to destroy
it in order to save us from it then what
kind of sense does that make right
that's that's nonsensical the world's a
bad place so we have to wipe out the
world well here's an option Slade why
not just make the world better like why
not just do that right up why not just
make the world a better place and so
Slade kind of realizing this to a degree
actually backs down and the fight more
or less comes to an end now this is
where things get really interesting and
really intriguing here because for the
most part it's DC setting everything
back to the status quo right families
reunited so you have Damien Wayne who's
back with uh who's back with Batman the
heroes who started it all have returned
the Justice Society of America is back
in full swing the Teen Titan are back at
Titan tower that Dr lied does Explore
her new powers and her new abilities so
finally for the first time in years Dr
Light has a purpose in DC Comics by
Justice League incarnate still exists
out there on the Multiverse they still
do their thing the uh the quintessence
has been restored to these Ultra
powerful beings who kind of help to
guide and keep an eye on everything
that's progressing darkseides return to
apocalypse right it's really kind of a
reset back to the status quo the only
real exception here is that Deathstroke
because of everything that had gone on
when the Great Darkness was pushed out
of its body it took all of his powers
with it so the guy has no healing factor
or anything he's just a guy he's in
constant pain all the time but he's just
a dude out there now this is where
things get wild and this is the point
that I was making to you guys so what Mr
terrific does is as he's sitting around
and talking to everybody that Mr
terrific ass is a tada right just one of
the more powerful magic wielders in DC
Comics and who's pretty knowledgeable
about the Multiverse he asked her what
did you find and she says the great
Darkness continues to to rest quiet
again and unconcerned with us it proves
that pariah's machine allowed him to tap
into just a fraction of the darkness's
true powers and so that's what Hal
Jordan asked so Pariah was never
connected to the great Darkness it was
all in his head the response of Hawkgirl
is what do we tell people that happen
here and Barry basically says nothing
right they can believe it was the great
Darkness if that will help ease their
worries now this is an exceedingly
important point to make and the reason
why is because what this means is all
the things that we saw Pariah do
bringing back the Multiverse and all
that kind of stuff that was simply just
a small infinitesimal portion of the
great darkness's abilities that if
Pariah was truly channeling the full
power of the great Darkness everybody
would have died like that they would
have died instantaneously there's
nothing they would have been able to do
because the great darkness's power is so
extreme now I love that Joshua
Williamson threw this in here and the
reason why is because for anybody who
knows anything about the great darkness
that biggest question they found
themselves asking here is how in the
world is any of this reconciled right
like how in the world can the great
Darkness be used by somebody and not
just obliterate everything in existence
instantaneously right how is it how
could the great Darkness Be So
astronomically powerful that it stands
as the equal and power but the opposite
of God and in turn have to kind of go
through all this these steps and this
great big huge long story arc and all
these processes just to infect and
spread into the dark multi or into the
Multiverse itself the response to Joshua
Williamson is because Pariah wasn't
really using any real measure of the
great darkness's power he was using a
little bit of it but not the full
totality of it which really begs the
question what would things have looked
like if Pariah really was channeling the
power of the great darkness in his full
totality and so following this as kind
of the last tidbit of this story what
you do is you switch over to Dick
Grayson and Batman and the reason why is
because as the two of them are here dick
Grayson kind of presents Batman with
this candle now for those of you guys
who Remembered in the death of the
Justice League Dick Grayson had a candle
in his hand that he had basically and
everybody else had a candle as well
right like a giant Candlelight vigil for
everybody else who was there it was a
vigil honoring the memories of the of
the the Justice League right all their
great deeds and the things that they had
done and so on and so forth for Dick
Grayson the candle in particular
represented hope and the reason why is
because when Bruce Wayne had taken Dick
Grayson under his wing and trained him
to become Robin it didn't happen
immediately instead Dick Grayson was
just the adopted son of Bruce Wayne
eventually Bruce Wayne revealed the
truth to Dick Grayson and when that
happened he and Dick Grayson made a vow
right the Robin's vow The Vow that dick
made when he became Robin that moment
with that candle signified hope it
signified that there was a future for
Dick Grayson outside of his family
having died that he could actually live
a life he could have some meaning right
the death of his family could have some
meaning in this world and that's what's
intriguing is because Dick Grayson
presents it to Batman and Batman in turn
snaps it in half and so where you can
initially see this as a bit of an insult
instead what Batman says is I appreciate
that you kept that candle I really
really do and he says after I put on the
cape and cow for the first time I was
alone on the streets of Gotham against
the darkness as it tried to drown me but
that candle was never the light in the
dark for me it was you right you Dick
Grayson were the one who kept me from
falling down to a very dark version of
myself and you have been that light for
everybody out here for every single
superhero people can say what they want
about Superman about him being the guy
that everybody looks up to and all that
kind of stuff but at the end of the day
he's kind of the moral guide for how we
should operate as superheroes but when
it comes to us falling to our darker
selves when it comes to us giving up
when we really really want to but in
turn moving away from that desire to
quit and keeping on the good path you're
the reason why we do that Dick Grayson
like you're the reason you you you are
the brightest and the best Among Us
right you are the light that keeps
superheroes from falling to the dark
it's a very very beautiful and touching
speech that Bruce Wayne gives to Dick
Grayson and so following this what Bruce
says is that there is no justice league
now that yes the Justice League was
quote unquote technically killed albeit
did Grace and never truly believed it
he's like but the Justice League was you
could call it disbanded for a period of
time and that led to Dick Grayson and
Jonathan Kent forming their own
superhero teams respectively and so on
but what Bruce says is that while the
members of the Justice League did come
back and while they all did face off
against Pariah and then slayed and the
day was saved the league is not
officially reformed and the reason why
is he says at the end of the day after
all we've been through the leak felt we
needed time to rethink the Justice
League as a team it needs more than just
new members it needs to find a new
Mission and needs to find a new Legacy
I.E this is DC Comics saying the Justice
League will return but it'll be
different uh because we're basically
gonna rework how the team how the team
roster functions and why individual
members were picked for that team we
have to craft a story around it yada
yada so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]